hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday december 27th
2021 what's going on how are you
oh it's the last monday of 2021 here we
go
limping along this decade hasn't this
decade just seem really long because of
the current situation with the
pandemicies
um
i went to i went to the movies yesterday
uh
me and my wife brought our lovely
daughter and uh went with another couple
and their lovely daughter we went out
saw that movie sing too
i don't remember seeing sing one i don't
know they all kind of blend together had
a great time really
that's a good it's a good kid movie to
go see i give it two freckled thumbs up
uh lots of laughs
uh the kids loved it and uh parents
enjoyed it too
and um
we went down to this there's this mall
area out here called the grove
there's a couple of them you know what i
mean they have like a trolley that
[ __ ] drives people around they're
always playing like
bing crosby and tony bennett and frank
sinatra
you know
that really white music that makes you
feel like you're
accomplishing things you know my kind of
town chicago is
the summer wind
it came blowing in
well i bought some underwear
i went across the street
to the [ __ ] bookstore and couldn't
believe they were still open
doesn't everybody
just read [ __ ]
on the [ __ ] laptop computers
let's go stand by the fountain
and take a picture by the christmas tree
right
everybody's walking around like 99
people have mass on this [ __ ] and every
once in a while you just see that
[ __ ]
rebel not having a mask on it's just
it's like they want to get it
these people are fascinating to me i
want to get covered
and i'm going to get covert and i'm not
going to die and then i'm going to prove
that the way i look at it is right
um
yeah strange people
you would never do that with the common
cold would you would you like go out of
your way to get it on purpose
um not to com not to be one of those
morons comparing it to the common cold
oh yeah it's like a common cold yeah
yeah guys i remember when i get it when
i get a [ __ ] cold i lose two of my
five senses but fortunately it seems
like you know it's it's starting you
know to mutate where it's not as bad
because you know i guess the virus
doesn't want to kill its host so it's
finally doing its dishes
it's becoming a a decent roommate so
things are looking up and then
i figure at some point it won't be that
big a deal and then everybody got the
vaccine
we'll say see we were right and then
everybody who didn't get it will say no
no no we were right
and it's not going to [ __ ] matter
because
you know the virus is going to be a good
roommate
then everybody can feel like they're
right
and uh i don't know we can go we can go
back to [ __ ] walking around a mall
you know
just buying [ __ ]
how that [ __ ] trolley doesn't hit
people is is really uh
is really just beyond me
um
i i don't know but i just love that the
non-mass people and when they walk by
you that [ __ ] look on their face
as they try and like you know
looking at you i'm looking just like wow
buddy
you know don't you like being healthy
right and they just kind of looking at
you it's all a [ __ ] lie man
you [ __ ] sheeple
um whoever what i mean i'm rooting for
them i mean i hope they're right
you know help them and their friends and
their think tank they help they're right
um
anyway all right let's let's get it out
of the way oh jesus christ now you know
when you have a big when your team has a
big football game
and i know all you stupid table breaking
[ __ ] you can't wait for this [ __ ]
moment right
um
you know there's there's two ways of
doing it you can either be a class act
or you can be like all right whatever
buffalo beat the patriots you have fun
losing in the playoffs man you know be
one of those [ __ ] people
how many [ __ ] you know be like a
yankee fan how many championships do you
have though you know we did things
before
more times than you did
um
i'm not doing either all right
if you like football you had to enjoy
how the buffalo bills came out on that
first [ __ ] drive they came out like
[ __ ] you
you [ __ ] afc east champions every
goddamn year
[ __ ] you bill belichick
i'm sick of everybody saying what a
great coach you are
we're just gonna ram this [ __ ] ball
right down your throat that first drive
after like three plays i was like oh
[ __ ] they came here to play and i was
screaming at the tv
to my team going all right you gotta
match this [ __ ] energy you have to
snuff out this hope that they have that
they're gonna come into our place and
[ __ ] win and they didn't and they
went down the [ __ ] field on the first
drive
get all the way down to the goal line
and inexplicably fourth and two they
don't kick a field goal this new way the
kids coach
[ __ ] it we're going for it
and i'm like this is the stupidest
[ __ ] thing i've
this is this new stupid way of coaching
and guess what it worked
they scored the touchdown then we get
the ball back
we have a fourth down on our own 50. i'm
like kick it we go for it
run a sweep on a fourth and [ __ ] two
or something and we make it i'm just
like i give up i don't unders maybe the
[ __ ] analytic people are right
i don't know
but anyway um
yeah buffalo just jumped on us the same
way the colts did last week and by the
time we got our [ __ ] together
it was too little too late um hats off
to buffalo big big big big big [ __ ]
win
and um
you know having said that
i'm still excited
i'm still bummed out but i'm a little
i'm i'm really excited where the
patriots are at we're a very young team
we have a really good defense and um we
got a great quarterback and all of that
type of stuff and i think uh
you know the future's bright for us this
just
is not
our year you know i'm done singing my
song
it's beginning to look a lot like 2001 i
thought we had i thought we had the
magic going but um
the colts and the bills as much as i
hate to say it brought us back to
reality
but
there's also still two weeks left and
anything can [ __ ] happen buffalo can
have a letdown game and all of a sudden
we win we'd still be uh you know we
still split
one game each buffalo drops the next two
we win the next two i think we would win
it i have no idea i don't have time to
look at the [ __ ] standings
um
i will tell you when i walked around the
grove i saw quite a bit of buffalo bills
gear which really bugged me i'm like ah
you [ __ ] [ __ ] where was this [ __ ]
all year
[ __ ] you [ __ ] put it on you take
it off then you put it back on again
i see how that works
actually i know i live in los angeles
what the [ __ ] do i know about buffalo
gear
um
all i know is that buffalo is is
you know they should have a sad sports
fan hall of fame there
[Laughter]
so you just you can't root against
i mean i guess you could but you can't
root against the bills
you know you can't root against the
sabres
i mean jesus christ
i mean what are you what are you going
to do out there i mean what what the
[ __ ]
i'm trying to think in all the history
of the buffalo sabres
1999 dominic hashick
you know the [ __ ] dude was standing
in the crease they called it all year
biggest goal of the year and they just
still uh nah it's all right
it's all right just you know it's fine
it's what the nhl does
listen you can't play
this style of hockey anymore all right
you can't be [ __ ] uh i can't have
these guys going out beating the [ __ ]
out of people running goaltenders you
know you just can't play that game
anymore we're trying to expand the
appeal of the game people seem to like
olympic hockey
you can no longer play bruins hockey and
then along comes the st louis blues and
they're just allowed to play that way
and we're sitting there with like we
[ __ ] emptied our [ __ ]
goon cabinet and we're just standing
there with a bunch of finesse players
wait a minute i thought you couldn't do
this
no for some reason this year's okay
no it wasn't okay for the whole year
well we're just in the playoffs for this
one team that they can do it
uh okay
i guess
i guess it's hockey so it makes no
[ __ ] sense
you know and then you got the [ __ ]
bill i like how i i still [ __ ] of
bruins fan about i'll never get over
that [ __ ] series not that we lost the
way we lost
to a lesser talented team that i watched
beat
who they beat nashville
san jose and the bruins and they were
not a better hockey team than either one
of any of those [ __ ] teams and they
were just allowed to beat the other team
down to their [ __ ] talent level with
their mediocre [ __ ] goalie
they then [ __ ] sat there this like
reminds me of patrick warren 1986. oh
does it
does that i remember patrick wagon he
pulled out of a [ __ ] game in the
finals
um sorry
final
it'd be a finals stanley cup final
is that how it works and then the bill's
losing four [ __ ]
super bowls in a row and as if that
wasn't enough
the shining star
the face of their franchise
goes out and kills
some woman and uh and the guy
you know she was hooking up with
i mean that you realize that was
the biggest victory of a buffalo bill in
the ninth over the last [ __ ] 30 years
was o.j simpson getting acquitted
i mean how the [ __ ] do you
how do you root against that
oh [ __ ] and i gotta tell you josh allen
i mean you know
that son of a [ __ ]
hats off to him
all right
actually honorable mention
for a big buffalo win
was last year uh this this past year
january 6th
when that shirtless yoga guy with the
buffalo bills hat
you know made it all the way to the
podium there at the washington capital
only to go wide right and then be
branded a terrorist
i still can't believe those people don't
understand that they're terrorists
they think they're patriots and they
learned a valuable lesson the difference
between a patriot
and a terrorist
is who wins
[Music]
all our founding fathers in this country
were [ __ ] terrorists they were
treasonous they were traitors but they
won
so now their faces are on our money that
[ __ ] guy there on january 6 he came
so close to being a face on our money
they just didn't have a plan you know
what it was they didn't plan to win
i don't think they thought they were
gonna get that far and then when they
got all the way in there they didn't
know what to do
they were just running around sitting at
desks
taking pictures just incriminating
themselves just in case you don't have
enough video of me
here's a picture of me on my own social
media platform
inside the [ __ ] place i just broke
into
thank you very much
uh
i don't know i don't know what else they
could have done just [ __ ] put
handcuffs on themselves
they're calling us terrorists
the [ __ ] guy
that [ __ ] guy crying
oh my god
[ __ ] whining at a goddamn airline
yeah buddy you just broke into the
nation's capital you're lucky you're not
getting hung by the nearest [ __ ] tree
that's what used to happen back in the
day you tried to pull some [ __ ] like
that
you would have been killed
now you just can't fly delta
[ __ ] babies
um
anyway
speaking of babies i'm gonna be in
phoenix arizona
all right the big traveling baby i love
this game i love this gig
because it's [ __ ] right next door i
got two shows on thursday these are my
final two shows of 2021
um
very excited so i'm going to try to uh
you know go there i'm i'm building up my
new hour
um
which by the way i've heard nothing but
[ __ ]
unbelievable rave reviews
for uh louis ck's new stand-up special
um
i gotta check that out at some point
although i gotta be honest with you i
don't watch stand-up specials
i don't watch them
you know what i mean does a plumber come
home and then turn on the tv and watch
somebody [ __ ] repair a sink
no they do not
what do you do for a living do you build
websites do you then go home and put on
the website channel
and go oh god i can't wait to watch an
hour of somebody building a [ __ ]
website i just can't do it i don't know
what happened i used to watch him all
the time and now um
i can't remember the last time i watched
the stand-up special
there i said it
yeah i don't think i've watched a
stand-up special in 10 years
probably more
yeah
i just realized that
you know
i got mine edited though
that's the one i watched i watched the
one that i do
and i get through that and i [ __ ] got
through it
two days
two days of editing
looking at my big stupid bald head i got
my kovid weight on
oh my god
i mean jesus christ
after that i never wanted to watch
another one again but
i'm not saying that you should
this is the worst [ __ ] promo for
anything ever
whatever what do you want from me how'd
you guys do on christmas
did you get everything you wanted
what did you
um i had a great christmas because um
i got i bought good gifts this year
you know every year i buy gifts but this
year
you know
i really knew what the [ __ ] was that
sound
oh it's the sprinklers
i thought there was a [ __ ] cat
hissing outside
um
yeah i'm doing it like this is like six
in the morning i had to wake up before
the kids
were uh
were up here to knock this thing out
um
yeah i always buy gifts but this year
like
the uh like my daughter really really
really wanted a skateboard
i really wanted a skateboard that's all
she kept talking about
and santa claus just kind of bring me my
skateboard and everything so um
she got the thing and absolutely freaked
out
she wants to take lessons and stuff and
she's all like she's all about my my
daughter's so [ __ ] cool it's
ridiculous
so
um she got the skateboard you know
what's funny was she wanted a spider-man
skateboard
right so i go to [ __ ] target i go to
the superstore
i'm walking around with all these
mouth-breathing [ __ ] sky
jackasses right
and i'm in my ego and i'm walking around
like i'm better than this man i'm better
than this superstore
right and i'm fighting the feeling as
i'm in there that i kind of like the
store
how convenient it is
to have these no-name
brand clothes that get the job done
and a couple aisles over i can get my
grocery shopping done
and there's a toy section
that i can bring my kid to
so she can uh test out the toys
you know
i completely lost my train of thought
what the [ __ ] was i talking about going
over to target
oh yes i go over to target you know
no no i was online that's what it was i
was online and i looked up
this spider-man [ __ ] marvel comic you
know
skateboard
and like that thing [ __ ] sucks i'm
not buying that
i'm not buying i'm gonna buy a go to a
[ __ ] old school skateboard and shop
out here i'm gonna buy a [ __ ]
a deck
as they call it
and then get a truck
that's what they call the thing you
stick the wheels on and all that i'll
get that [ __ ] right
and then i'll just [ __ ] find somebody
to paint the bottom and put a [ __ ]
spider-man thing on it right
so
i asked the guy at the shop and he goes
yeah i got just the guy
so all right cool
so uh he goes how do you want me to do
this i can do it like you know i can do
like a screen thing graphic blah blah
blah i said buddy i go just do it right
do it upright and he's like all right
and this [ __ ] guy
i can't even tell you what he created on
the bottom it's unbelievable it's like
it's a [ __ ] painting
and he thought i was just gonna hang the
thing on the walls like no she's going
to skate this thing
because she's going to skate because
dude this is like
you know
a piece of art man like the guy like
signed it and [ __ ]
but i was just like well i mean i don't
i told you she was going to skate we had
like a miscommunication so we were both
laughing
and he goes why don't you just save this
one and put it on the wall and then run
over to target i'm like because it's
[ __ ] christmas eve
and i was just like [ __ ] it she's going
to skate the thing so i think it's going
to look cool she's just going to scuff
up the the the
the ends of it and it's going to look
like stevie ray vaughan's guitar you
know what i mean that's how i look at it
although i got to tell you though she
hasn't skated yet because it's been
raining out here i just keep looking at
it it is so [ __ ] beautiful
there's like
he has like the sky on the on the back
end of it right you have like the sky
that he did like in purple with clouds
then he has my my daughter's
name written on it
like how with the with like the
you know like on batman was like pow
biff you know that
jagged like cloud thing
and then he has like all like the in
green
like the city
behind him
and then just [ __ ] spider-man in the
middle like
i think like pointing
right at you looking at the highlights
unbelievable
and then it kind of has like this jagged
thing
where it's like
almost like the end of reality
like it ends the cityscape and then it
just goes into that new spider-man logo
towards the front of it i mean it is a
[ __ ]
masterpiece
it is a [ __ ] masterpiece
and the trucks we got are the same color
red as the spider-man suit and then the
wheels we got were purple which matched
the sky i mean it's the sickest [ __ ]
looking skateboard
you ever seen in your life and it's
funny you know my daughter's only four
so she looks at she's like oh cool
i knew i was getting a skateboard i
asked santa for a skateboard i knew he
was getting
skateboards she wants to go out there
and um
whatever
whatever um
so i got her all the pads and all that
type of stuff and uh
i'm gonna uh
get her some skateboarding lessons and
all that type of [ __ ] so
i guess i'm gonna be in that world now
the skateboarding world um
so anyway uh
tonight
i'm gonna go run out go try to go do
some [ __ ] stand up somewhere i gotta
find somewhere i can be
um
because when i was i was working in
indiana indianapolis i was doing like 25
30 new minutes since my uh
my red rocks thing
um some stuff that i already been
[ __ ] with and then new [ __ ] that i
had some stuff left over and everything
so i'm trying to do is put this whole
thing together so i can put out the red
rocks thing as soon as possible
um
that is the game plan
and then i'll just [ __ ] move on from
there i've also you know i got an acting
gig coming up so billy billy political
been doing like an hour a day although
yesterday i [ __ ] negated everything
when i went to the goddamn movie theater
you know
it's just popcorn candy all of that
[ __ ] [ __ ] then all the parents we all
went out to dinner after that so
i don't know
[ __ ]
i just can't i don't want to fight this
has been the hardest it's ever been for
me to lose weight i just every time i
[ __ ] get going i have a road date or
just something a holiday
but
i just said i'm just gonna do an hour of
cardio every [ __ ] day until this
shoot starts in like mid-february
towards the end of february and i should
be all right
um
so anyway that is it i want to thank
everybody that listened to the jim
gaffigan podcast the two-parter that i
did
um
speaking of stand-up specials he has one
out called comedy monster
um
just absolutely [ __ ]
hilarious human being if you haven't had
a chance to listen to it last week's
monday morning podcast and the thursday
afternoon one was a two-parter thing
with the great jim gaffigan who
i met
um
maybe my second or third day when i
moved to new york and he was brand new
too
and we had gone down to the um
what had become of the improv
where
bud freeman's wife her name escapes me
still owned the improv name in new york
city
and um
yeah there was a famous story part of
the divorce
where she got the improv in new york
and that her husband was not allowed to
[Music]
you know open another improv like within
a hundred miles or something
of new york city
i don't know what i whatever 150 miles
200 i have no idea what it was and all i
know whatever the mileage was
bud opened one in atlantic city
and his ex-wife got in the car set the
trip odometer and drove down there
and the thing was like two miles within
you know
the limit he could not be in
and she [ __ ] had him shut it down
it was brutal so anyway
she owned the improv name
and the improv now was at the back of a
restaurant
and the light to tell you to get off
stage was her flashing a pen light at
you
and um
that's the first place i met jim
gaffigan
so i've known that guy was 1995.
i can't believe it i've known that guy
for [ __ ] 26 years jesus christ um
anyway but he absolutely destroyed it so
anyway let me quit babbling here let's
do a little bit of the uh oh i don't
have any advertising
what am i talking about i don't have
any um
i don't have any advertisers this week
because they all know you guys all blew
all your money what'd you hey hey
freckles what did you get i got i got a
bunch of great gifts
for christmas
i got a bunch of dad gifts and i loved
it
i loved it i got a i got some new
underwears
i got a an electric shaver
for my bald head
this thing called the pitbull
and uh i'm kind of addicted to it
you know
i don't know if it's better than a blade
it's just easier
and it's faster
i know it's just easy you just turn it
on you just [ __ ] run it over your
head
then i'm kind of learning how to use it
the most effectively
and um
yeah it's going to be great for when i
go go on the road because now i don't
have to bring like shaving cream and be
like is this too much [ __ ] liquid
am i gonna run out
blah blah blah blah i don't have to
worry about any of that stuff so
hopefully
i've solved that problem
oh you know i was on instagram last
night because i'm a [ __ ] 12 year old
girl right i'm on instagram and um
they're making fun of [ __ ] [ __ ]
peoples that drive teslas and have like
those vanity plates that talk about gas
what's that
lol gas
no gas blah blah blah blah
and all these [ __ ] douche bags
like that's not dumb enough all of these
douche bags i swear to god like 80 of
them were just like
and um where do you think electricity
comes from
making the point that you need uh fossil
fuels to create electricity every like i
swear to god
like 80 of the comments were that it's
like haven't you read that everybody's
already made this point
you dumb [ __ ]
and they're all going like yeah this is
just like the new glorified prius it's
like
yeah no it isn't
no it isn't a tesla is not a glorified
prius a tesla is the fastest car in the
[ __ ] road and none of those [ __ ] can
[ __ ] admit it
you know
none of those gas driving [ __ ]
this is just like masked people versus
unmasked people and nobody sees you know
that we're all a bunch of [ __ ]
right
myself included
like people with gas cars don't have
those stupid vanity plates
all those [ __ ] morons who have an
incredibly small amount of horsepower
but you'd never know it from how loud
their exhaust is
driving down the [ __ ] street
and it's like i can still see you
i've heard your car
for 10 minutes i can still see you on
the highway
anytime they just barely step on the gas
it makes so much [ __ ] noise
to give the illusion that their car is
actually fast and it isn't
it's just loud
now i'm not giving motorcycle people
[ __ ] your bike should be loud because
people can't see it but if they can hear
you that's how you stay alive
right so i don't mind a loud motorcycle
but what i do i there should be a rule
if your car is loud it has to be fast
remember gas monkey garage fast and loud
it just wasn't loud
oh my god these [ __ ] idiots with
their [ __ ]
there's actually something you now can
stick into your exhaust
to make it sound louder
to make it sound like
you know
i don't know it's like you're lying
about your dick size
you got a regular old dick and you're
making the noise like you're a [ __ ]
porn star
you know
and all these gas driving [ __ ] car
[ __ ]
with their uh stupid vanity plates you
lose
bye bye and all of this [ __ ] making all
of this [ __ ] noise
when
there's a silent car that makes no
[ __ ] noise that will with [ __ ] two
kids in kid's seats and groceries in the
back
will [ __ ] destroy you
[ __ ] destroy you
my car makes noise and smoke comes out
of it these [ __ ] quiet cars
where do you think the electricity comes
from and then the [ __ ] idiots driving
the electric cars like oh f have fire
fight the gas station
it's like why can't you just buy what
you like and shut the [ __ ] up
you know in a perfect world
somebody with a gas driving car
with a you lose
license plate
we'll have a head-on collision with
someone in a tesla
you know
with their
gas
question mark lol can you get a question
mark on a license plate i don't know
in a perfect [ __ ] world
in a world
that is perfect they would have a
head-on collision the airbags come out
you know and they both get out a little
groggy and they go into that little tent
on the side of the [ __ ] uh nfl game
they come out everybody's fine
and then the police officer like uh yeah
your cars are totaled you're both at
fault
uh all we could save is your license
plates
you know and then they both have to go
sit at a [ __ ]
bus stop
because all the uber people are busy
that day or maybe they don't want to
work
whatever whatever the [ __ ] goes on at
uber
you know
this is a high volume time there's not a
lot of
whatever one of those times and they
just both have to sit there and they
have to work out their differences
you know
just sit there you know it's kind of
funny
that both of us took the time out of our
[ __ ] lives
to fill out a piece of paper at the
[ __ ] dmv
to get a customized license plate who
the [ __ ] has time to do that
who gives a [ __ ]
that much
there has to be something online there
has to be some sort of
psych psychiatry [ __ ] think tank is
that how you say it
the kind of person
let me just look up people
who get
custom
licensed oops i spelt it wrong of course
plates
okay personal interest specialized
license place what you need to know
about vanity plates what drives people
to take
vanity license plates
okay
here's one maryland
it's w-e-h-v-f-u-n
we have fun
performance coach caroline adam miller
says
vanity plates can boost self-esteem
pictured her own
we have fun
to boost state coffers texas sold a
dallas doctor
a porsche
for 7 500.
then it sold him america for 3 000.
what does that mean both were license
plates sold at auction
i will get my american citizenship next
month so it means a lot to me
says salman wahed
an intensive care
physician
he wanted ferrari but dropped out
when bidding for that went too high
eventually netting fifteen thousand
dollars the top price paid the [ __ ]
car says ferrari
it says it right on your case you didn't
you know
just crossing all the t's and dotting
all the eyes
after years of selling vanity plates at
a modest sideline charging as little as
five dollars states think that there's
more money to be made and whatever
drives people to buy them
facing budget crisis states are right
raising surcharges or proposing annual
fee hikes for custom plates
texas has gone a step further as they
always do
there's another step to take you know
texas is going to take it and it's going
to be a bigger step than any other state
because we're big
it hired a private company to raise 25
million
over the next five years by auctioning
off vanity plates
people like to express themselves
especially in texas
i am from massachusetts we don't like to
express ourselves we do but not the way
they like to in texas um said like what
when what [ __ ] where is that
that whole statement what what world is
that [ __ ] based in
people like to express themselves okay
well there's a bold statement okay yeah
everybody likes to express something
especially in texas
that's just to go for the [ __ ]
you know
hacky applause bro that's right yeah
it's [ __ ] right man
expressing myself right now my belt
buckle
um
says a spokesperson for a texas
department of motor vehicles
this year that is just literally
they're just chumming the water of
mouth-breathing morons
people like to express themselves i like
to express myself especially in texas
i'm from texas that's right
it's my god-given right to express
myself and you're getting i'm saying
everybody in texas is dumb
all right i'm not saying that i'm just
saying that you have a lot of dumb
people there because you have more
[ __ ]
real estate
so everything's going to be higher okay
i'm sure you have a higher level of uh
you know
super smart people
that realize maybe i don't need a shiny
pickup truck considering i don't own a
ranch
and just because i'm in texas
i don't really need a four-wheel drive
pickup truck because i'm not going to go
four-wheeling anyway maybe you know
i think that's where the bar is
in texas for intelligence to actually
not buy a pickup truck realizing that
you don't need one
you
know do you know how many people don't
need pickup trucks and actually have
them myself included
um
that's why the four-door cab
is so [ __ ] popular i [ __ ] hate the
four-door cab because you don't have a
bed anymore
it's basically a [ __ ] rumble seat
it's like what the [ __ ] did you get a
pickup truck for if most of the truck is
gonna be you know where you bring in
your construction crew that isn't doing
construction
you know
anyway sorry um
and then they go especially in texas and
this is just gonna get people
well i'm from texas and
you're supposed to buy a pickup truck so
i'm about to pick up trucking and the
same people i just rushed myself i need
to express myself right says the
spokesperson for the texas department of
motor vehicle this year at the nation's
first auction texas sold 33 plates for
in the u.s there's room for vanity to
grow oh jesus just we thought we
couldn't be more about ourselves despite
having 9.3 million motor vehicles with
vanity plates the 46 states that charged
annual fees for them collectively raised
only about 177 million
so now they're just going to make them
more expensive
because there's no money left because
we're just having never-ending wars and
we don't [ __ ] own our own currency
anymore the potential market is huge
many motorists such as 60-year-old lee
weaver are devoted to their plates even
if they may cause trouble mr weaver
lives in virginia
but he's a hardcore boston red sox fan
whose license plate says
eight bow socks
what's that karya strumsky
well nobody in virginia gives a [ __ ]
about the red sox his toyota solara has
been scratched to pieces he says oh wow
oh they probably just don't like because
he's a yankee and he's endured insults
and obscene gestures on the highway
especially when he's driving north on
i-95 near new york
yet rather than opting for less
noticeable plates he he wouldn't get rid
of his in a million years he says i
absolutely love my tags all right i'm
out of here i can't read any more of
this all right worst
vanity plates let's get let's get this
going here
all right the 10 worst license plates
ever approved
all right what do we got here
nominate this for one of the 10 worst
[ __ ] websites
oh all kinds of ads oh god am i in this
i'm in this part of the internet
uh oh wait a minute
this is a bad one
this one one of the vanity plates says
it's lstn
space
cnt
which a quick glance reads listen [ __ ]
wow
oh my god
i don't even know what the x-e-s-t-t-u-b
now that i've made fun of all of these
people i can't figure out what that's
supposed to say
been trying to post this all day read
more
what does this one mean
here's a tesla owner with lol oil
plates
displaying some of the trademark
smugness that these people
hate these otherwise
that makes people hate these otherwise
cool electric sports cars
[Laughter]
yeah and also you know
it's it's not like it didn't take a
bunch of raw materials to make your car
it's just different raw materials
right
well it's still plastic i guess lithium
for all the batteries
anyway have you ever seen a more pitiful
embarrassing plate than this it could be
either a custom license plate or just
very unfortunate set of random state
issues no i don't think it was
um
pull out p-u-l
o-u-t
and it says choose life
that is [ __ ] unbelievable
look at these websites this is how you
lose like a [ __ ] three hours of your
life
and the winner for most beautiful women
woman goes to
there's some beautiful woman with her
perfect tits [ __ ] hanging out of her
shirt
man gives girlfriend a necklace two
years later she screams
when she realizes
mature trainer this is what ripped old
guys do differently
top heart surgeons this simple trick
helps empty your bowels every morning
well what does a heart surgeon know
about your ass
wear these shoes you can walk for hours
without discomfort
jesus christ how old am i those are my
selections
how to be ripped as an old guy how to be
able to take a [ __ ] and how to walk in
some sneakers that won't hurt your feet
because why i search for most annoying
vanity plates
all right i apologize well whatever i'm
an old man
all right let's get to the reads here
for this week
um
you know somebody by the way sent me i
might jump to the last one here somebody
sent me this thing
on
airlines and frequent flyer miles by the
way there's only three major long
distance
airlines
left in the united states united
american and delta i didn't even realize
that
i'm thinking whatever happened to
eastern airlines pan am twa
northwest
airlines you know
at least we still got southwest all
right
um
yeah so this guy sent this video
said airlines have become banks
hey oh billy boozles
big fan of all the stuff you do and
thanks for helping me keep me sane
through the last few years i'll cut to
the chase and just recommend this video
that explains how the airline loyalty
programs are actually
the only way they make money thought it
would be up your alley
so
the name of the video is
if you want to search for the first time
sorry it's called uh
how airlines quietly became banks
it's just basically talking about how
what gives the airline value is not the
planes and all of that [ __ ]
it's their frequent flyer mile programs
and that the way that they're able to
manipulate it
move it around like there used to be i
guess ways to beat the frequent flyer
system you know you see those people
that just flew
i didn't understand they just sort of
flew around the world
for miles so they wouldn't have to pay
but it was like
i don't know it was just this whole
weird
thing where someone would just fly to
hong kong and back
and then go to you know fly over to
singapore and [ __ ] and like i don't know
if they can do that anymore because the
idiots made videos on how to do it
so the airline's like oh is that how
you're cheating this system and then
they just closed all those loopholes but
anyway they were talking about how
their value is basically in their
frequent flyer miles
and that is treated as currency so
they're able to
determine
[Music]
you know the value of their currency
where if you were to fly from washington
dc to nantucket or to boston it's the
same amount of miles
but because you're probably richer if
you go to nantucket you don't get as
many miles and the plane ticket costs
more
for convenience and blah blah i don't
[ __ ] know all i know is there's no
money in aviation and i don't give a
[ __ ] what the airlines are doing
because
i can't believe they can stay in
business
so if this is what they have to do i
don't give a [ __ ] but it was definitely
interesting all right let's get on to
the uh
the gaffigan podcast here
bill um as i mentioned i interviewed jim
gaffigan um
uh
was supposed to only be a half hour
thursday and we talked for like an hour
and 40 minutes so it became the monday
morning thursday afternoon podcast last
week
gaffigan podcast bill you outdid
yourself that was the best podcast of
the year
uh for those who haven't listened it
starts off we just talk comedy and all
that stuff we talk specials we just
talked to business and then somewhere
along the line we just started [ __ ]
on each other just making fun of each
other and gaffigan's one of the best at
doing that and um
and we just had it we just had such a
great [ __ ] time anyways also louie's
new special is hilarious
uh critics would be jerking off to it
had the mainstream streaming outlets not
been [ __ ] uh thanks for all the
podcasts in 2021 anything better is a
great addition version is hilarious
uh love to the family
from georgia
you guys got vanity plates out there
georgia peach
south's going to rise again
let's see here
top
georgia
vanity plates you know you know all my
advertising this week is just going to
be vanity
uh
oh here's one
number one
georgia fan
there's one that says girl with the
georgia bulldog g on it
survivor
oh god cancer survivor
oh my god so then people are [ __ ]
pulling up alongside like did she
recently survive
what does it look like to have just
survived cancer
i need to pass on the left to see what
this looks like
um
cancer survivor and then what if the
person behind you just lost somebody to
cancer
ah i won i beat k you can't beat cancer
i did
all right indy everybody
hey billy ball buster i went to s uh i
went with my wife to see your second set
friday night
in indianapolis and you did not
disappoint
my wife was not used to your style of a
fandom and then pull them back to your
side so it was fun to watch your
reactions
most of your observations about indiana
were accurate including the history of
the clan
uh in the rural areas oh i just kept
giving them [ __ ] about that
[Music]
[Laughter]
i was saying how i understood hate
groups
in the middle of the country you know
what i mean
because like the farmers once they cut
down their crops they're paying tax on
land that they're not really using at
that point
so they just host it you know they host
a hate group rally
that's like
i was asking them if a clan rally was
like the rave of indianapolis where
instead of glow sticks they had burning
crosses i was having a good time out
there
um
anyways uh this guy says uh the history
of the klan rallies and he spelled clan
c-l-a-n it's k-l-a-n right kkk the coup
klux klan for a long time i said klu
klux klan i thought it was all that it's
cool
uh but despite the fact that the crowd
that night was mostly white indianapolis
is about 30 percent black which is the
same as chicago we also have an annual
black expo
uh where tyson got arrested
uh and there are several black
celebrities from indiana like mike epps
vivica fox and george hill
uh
i think the jokes about indy not liking
black folks fell a little fl oh look at
this after he compliments me
he's now defending indianapolis
okay and this white person is gonna tell
me what black people feel like in
indianapolis okay i think the the jokes
about indy not liking black folks fell a
little flat not because it was offensive
but it was confusing
folks in the midwest are used to
outsiders not knowing [ __ ] about them
other than sports team just want to give
you a friendly heads up
also sorry you had to miss your patriots
play while you had another show here at
least you didn't have to watch their
asses lose in person
uh happy holidays and go [ __ ] yourself
um
sir
uh you might want to go [ __ ] look at
how black people are living in
indianapolis
which in fairness you could say that
about everywhere
it's still the same
thing indianapolis about 30 black people
oh so it's
still 70 white i don't understand what
any of that meant
you have famous black people from there
yeah as do all cities
that's not why it fell a little flat
fell a little flat because what i was
saying was true it's not truer than any
other city
but it just is what it is
all right
but thank you for chiming in
and they didn't fall a little flat it
fell a little flat between your ears it
was doing [ __ ] great
at no point when i was saying i said it
every show and i wasn't thinking like
gee that's odd it's falling a little
flat
it got the reaction i knew it was gonna
get
it was fun
anyway
thank you for chiming in and uh
congratulations on your regular season
win
all right greeting from africa
uh dear billy white devil
he writes just a joke all right forgive
my english the fact that you can talk
[ __ ] in a second language i'll never
that is so fascinating to me
um
i have used a translator to write this
paragraph ah all right that's not you're
cheating here i can speak english well
enough to understand but not write it as
good
that's pretty good i can read french
pretty well but i can't speak it very
well
i think what you're doing is better
the virus that has been ruining the
world seems to have hit africa
differently our doctors attribute to the
malaria medication we take regularly it
appears that this treatment has become
controversial in your country
and others despite keeping numbers low
and our population more healthy
than any other continent on the planet
now wait a second
all right
the viruses ruining the world seems to
have hit africa differently our doctors
attribute oh i was assuming that it hit
it worse and i was waiting for you to be
like you started off by saying the white
devil i thought you were going to say
that the white man created covid to
deliberately
kill uh africans
you're going the other way our doctors
attribute to the malaria medication we
take regularly it appears that this
treatment has become controversial in
your country and others despite keeping
numbers low
in our population more healthier than
any other continent on the planet well
yeah there's a lot of money in treatment
they want to make sure that you use
their treatment this is not nothing new
uh i'm sure that in your country there's
there's better malaria drugs they just
don't have enough money behind them
it's a dirty business keeping people
alive all right please don't speculate
that it is for other reasons as your
leaders in medicines have been doing to
discredit our doctors and methods why
would i speculate on that i'm not a
doctor
if i you know i'm not gonna
i'm not doing that [ __ ]
um our society is not but i did
speculate that you you do have diff
whatever
um our society is not as developed in
certain areas and it makes people think
we're all stupid minds
well i don't think that uh i believe you
will be interested in learning more
about this because you always fight to
know the truth now you're on the wrong
podcast buddy
i love your show and your mind brain
i love your mind break thank you for
introducing me to american football all
right well thank you for writing in sir
thank you for listening all the way over
there in africa i don't think that you
guys are stupid
um
i appreciate that you respect my mind
brain
um
no if you got something over there
that's working that's [ __ ] great then
eventually uh we will admit if it works
that it does work is once we figure out
how
you know
we can make money off of it and have the
biggest [ __ ] people control it
um
yeah i don't know i i i'm over all the
covet [ __ ] i don't even have the passion
to even fight i don't care i just think
that how it's gonna play out is how it's
gonna play out
and uh you know money's gonna win
overall
and but eventually i i do know that they
need to keep us alive because they don't
want to dig their own ditches
um that is one thing that to say that
they're out here trying to thin the
[ __ ] herd
um deliberately
um
and that if anybody gets a vaccination
they're going to die i don't know if you
want to say that it has it shortens your
life
if you get it
i don't know all right i'll go with that
so what
[Music]
gives a [ __ ] i don't care
i just don't give a [ __ ] all right i you
know what it is i don't have an ego as
far as my importance
okay
i know i am not a vital part of human
survival and i also understand that i am
still alive because they have allowed me
to be so if they decide that they want
to now get rid of me
then you know
i mean i should have been dead in 1980
when i had a [ __ ] ruptured appendix
but they kept me alive
you know
so like i'm already like
41 years
i've lived 41 years longer
they've allowed me to so i'm gonna get
mad that they're gonna take my last 15
that i you know i shouldn't even have
had i don't give a [ __ ]
just thought can you here's a question
for you guys if you could write if you
could just write it
okay
why do you think you're so important
or
what makes you
so god damn important
because it [ __ ] fascinates me
how important people think they are
and how much they think they [ __ ]
matter
now i'm not saying that i don't respect
other people i absolutely do and i don't
want to be an [ __ ] to you or whatever
but i mean just as far as like
how important and unique you think you
are when there's seven billion of us
just think about the way you kill ants
you just see one in your house you just
[ __ ] you do you ever just sit there and
be like that was that aunt's
one life
okay let's see how long do ants live
ants life
span
black garden ants live four years
pharaoh ants four to 12 months
can ants live up to 30 years can ants
live
what does somebody want it for a
lifelong pet
all right
i don't even like some of the [ __ ] that
i [ __ ] look up
anyway yeah
i think if everybody could just get over
themselves
you know
[ __ ] driving around with a vanity
plate you can't give a [ __ ] about your
stupid ideas
what kind of a douche buys a tesla
and then gets a vanity plate on it
rubbing it in the noses of other people
it's like most people can't afford a
tesla you [ __ ] [ __ ]
um
and then also people like yeah it's
gonna be a gas powered tow truck that's
gonna tow your car away when you [ __ ]
can't find a place to [ __ ] charge it
people
when you buy a tesla you get a charging
system put in at your house you plug it
in like a cell phone
stop acting like you constantly see
teslas on the side of the road out of
power
you charge them they have over 300 miles
all right
there was a problem when they first came
out it is no longer a problem there are
charging stations all over the place
for free
imagine if you went to the movies and
you pulled into a parking spot and you
just could fill your gas tank up
you didn't have to you just put the
nozzle in and it filled it up for you
for free
now eventually
once everybody has them they're not
going to be free
that's how it works but right now they
got to get people to switch over that's
what it is which i think is a good thing
you know because it will lessen our
dependency on oil hopefully
no i won't because oil [ __ ] runs our
country
my big thing is i just want us to have
no reason to be in the middle east so we
can just leave those people alone let
them solve their own [ __ ] problems
but there's too much money in it for us
anyway
dictator
hello billy big tears burr
i've often talked about being a dictator
slash president with my friends where
we'd go around and all present one
sweeping law that would be placed into
our society mine will combat the obesity
problem and here's how dude i love this
[ __ ]
i want i want to hear more of your
dictator ideas people
anyone over 500 pounds has one year to
get under the 500 pound threshold
are they are set up to be executed
um i think that number's a little high
buddy
you know
sure it sounds barbaric but when when
has anyone over 500 pounds contributed
anything meaningful to society
i just can't believe they stay alive
once you get so fat you can't leave your
[ __ ] house
you know
like how nice do you have to be i bet
people over 500 pounds are really nice
people
hey just want to let you guys know
how much i appreciate it that you go to
denny's every morning for me and get me
13 grand slam breakfasts before you you
guys actually walk out the door and go
to work
and i just lay on my [ __ ]
sore ridden bat eating [ __ ] pancakes
um
never yeah i mean just every day you get
to stay home
i mean it is miserable
those have to be long weeks but i mean
there is just something to say just like
just laying in a big bed just eating
anything you want to eat
and just keep going not out you know
just chowing
[ __ ] watching cartoons
um
the first year okay never once okay wait
wait wait sure it sounds barbaric but
when has anyone over 500 pounds
contributed anything meaningful to
society never once
that's not true
they think we used to [ __ ] stand in
the carnivals
look how fat he is oh my god right
they used to bring an income it's a roll
it's a rolling annual event so you can't
just balloon up after that mark the
first year the limit is 500 oh i jumped
in too soon and each year since the
limit is dropped 25 pounds until it's
400 pounds
uh
in reached
in a few years which will remain the
constant benchmark it promotes health
and their lives are truly in their own
hands a true win-win looking forward to
seeing you in saratoga next year and
best wishes to you and the family
provided they all under 500 pounds
obviously well why would you stop at 400
pounds
just then make it 375 down to 350.
you know then all those offensive
linemen
if you play an nfl football or college
football you can be over like 300 pounds
or if you're past a certain height
you know there'd have to be some
loopholes
oh man that'd be [ __ ] unreal
what a way to stay in shape stay in
shape or you're gonna die wait a minute
that's what doctors say you know what it
is it's because it's there's not like an
actual date
um
um i like it i i think i would root i i
i would vote for that you can't rope
vote for a dictator i would be rooting
for your military coup
all right mayfield prep
um
hey billy imperial blaster master the
guy's name is mayfeld
migs mayfield not mayfield
although i thought it was mayfield for a
while too uh what's up bill long time
listener and fan and happy to see you
crushing it with the acting thank you
speaking of acting for the scene with
you
with officer you blasted for his
decision that cost the lives of your
character's brother and zaram did you do
any research or talk to any vets i asked
because you [ __ ] crushed it yes
thank you
i wrote this email your delivery was
[ __ ] flawless
see now these are the kind of
compliments a married man needs to hear
there's a [ __ ] great program
you know perfect strangers come up
and compliment a married man so he
remembers what that sounds like
anyway he goes i got chills watching the
look you had
in tone
and i could connect with that character
you nailed the sense of humor with no
[ __ ] attitude and we need we need to
have to survive not just in war but back
in the world
i'd love to see a spin-off centered
around you and that character anyways i
really would like to know how you'd prep
specifically for that scene
if you could share thanks and go [ __ ]
yourself a retired army vet uh
two iraq and one afghan afghanistan i
guess he was three tours over there
jesus christ
um how did i prepare for that um
it was kind of all there on the page i
just read the scene
and i was like oh wow this is going to
be the [ __ ]
i knew it was going to be a great scene
and i knew that i was in there with
great actors and rick family was
family he was directing it so i was like
all right
um
how did i you know i connect with pain
[Music]
that's all i can tell you
so even though i didn't experience that
specific pain
i am able to tap into other [ __ ] that
happened to me
um
[Music]
or the combination of that or just
having empathy or something like that i
you know what i honestly don't know i'm
kind of afraid to pull it apart
but um
yeah now that you know what it is is you
just bring it to a place where you can
relate to it
so as much as that guy is playing you
know a commanding officer and anything a
commanding officer takes on many
different forms it's just a person that
has power over you
that was abusive so you're able to
sort of channel
that into those words i would say maybe
that's what it was and then also
um
you know the way it was written the
whole thing was it was just kind of
there but that's a really interesting
question that i didn't uh
i know i just read the scene i
immediately understood it and then
i remember
we were sort of blocking the scene and i
remember standing
looking
[Music]
over where i was going to be sitting and
i was already emotionally like
to the point i was like all right stop
thinking about it are you gonna [ __ ]
do the scene before the scene happens
so
um yeah i would say with something like
that
i believe yeah something like that and
then also
and then after that you're like okay now
i can i can relate to this thing
then you just make choices
that aren't going to be obvious
you know
like i told you a few weeks ago when i
was at that green bay packer game and
that kid was being an [ __ ] so one of
my
buddies from back massachusetts just sat
down next to him moved me away from him
and the drunk guy looked at my buddy and
he goes
why are you here
and he just looked at him he had half a
smile and he goes why do you think i'm
here
you know and i was just remember like i
just remember moments like that for
acting where like if you saw that on a
paper on a page
as an actor you'd think you'd go you
know that's a badass line i got
delivered like a badass like why do you
think i'm here
you know which is
you know that's a way you could do it
but that's obvious and it just sort of
becomes cheesy but the way he did it
where he kind of had a smile on his face
you know and almost turned it into a
fatherly son relationship
with uh i'm not going to give you the
answer son but i'll help you get there
and then he had a half a smile on his
face that said you know i don't care
whether i win or lose i just enjoy
fighting
was a whole other
another level of intimidation and his
friends took that guy and moved him two
seats down
i just sort of clock those things
stick it in the memory bank and then
when you come up with the scene like
that
um
you have options
so it won't be like
hopefully stale
but i that's a unbelievable thrill that
you got that you actually lived what i
was pretending i lived and you connected
with it so i re i really appreciate that
um
and i'm glad you made it back after two
three tours over there jesus
all right don't [ __ ] with monkeys hey
billy big balls greetings from chicago
i'm a huge fan of the podcast and
recently ran across this news article
online it's the craziest story i've read
in a while and the headline is true art
i knew i had it to send it your way
thank you i appreciate it apparently a
group of monkeys in india are going on
revenge killings
against a town's dog population after a
dog killed a baby monkey
wow man yeah
you don't want to [ __ ] with monkeys man
the monkeys are snatching up the dogs
climbing up on top of something and then
throwing dogs to their deaths
well i gotta tell you something as far
as like how monkeys kill you that's
about as nice
a humane way they could do it apparently
the monkeys have nearly wiped out the
entire dog population in the town and
now the monkeys are turning on children
what
yeah see now they're drunk with power
they're just like people
i put the headline in the link
below if you want to check it out
yourself i this can't be real i know
it's a dark story but i kind of admire
the monkey's sense of community i feel
like the us should come together like
they do in times of advert like they do
in times of adversity
you want to start throwing children down
on the ground that didn't do anything
like start killing don't kill the thing
that [ __ ] killed kill all of them and
then move on to something else i think
we've already done that over here
um
gee i wish we could do that
enraged monkeys killed 250 dogs by
dragging them to the top of buildings
and dropping them off
uh all right there's already a billion
ads coming up on this so i'm really
wondering if this is real
um
dropping them off out of revenge after
pups kills one of their infants in
indian village
oh wait according to local reports there
are barely any dogs left
in la vu laval village villagers say
monkeys drag dogs up to the high place
and
drop them to the death but without any
dog targets the monkeys are now
reportedly turning on children
enraged monkeys have killed 250 dogs
panic-stricken residents have come under
attack and say
the acts of the animals violence has
been carried out in revenge
oh jesus christ
oh no
well there's a monkey doing it and rage
monkeys have
i'm just seeing these these pictures
of people who look upset
monkey in town hunts
dogs for revenge after infant killed
all right do i really want to watch this
picture in media shows a monkey on a
rooftop holding a dog
all right i don't see one throwing one
one of the monkeys appeared to go for a
child in the village before the dog ran
at the monkey
yeah
this really isn't a problem
i don't understand what the problem is
we're human beings they're monkeys solve
the [ __ ] problem
all right
put out a bunch of bananas and then
[ __ ] take out an uzi
then they can understand where they are
in the [ __ ] pecking order again
all right
jesus christ
[Laughter]
it's not like they're monkeys dressed up
like human beings and you can't figure
out who's the problem the problem is the
monkeys go kill the monkeys
all right airlines have become banks oh
this is what i was telling you guys
about you have to watch uh
that clip there oh man hour 15 minutes i
went way over here okay well that's it
everybody this is the podcast uh thank
you for all the um
you know all the letters thank you
everybody who came out to my shows this
year thank you everybody's gonna come
out to phoenix
uh another great year living my dream
thanks to all you guys that give a [ __ ]
to listen to my podcast
show up to my stand-up shows and watch
some of my acting work
um please continue to let me know what
you would do if you were a dictator um i
would think of some of that stuff
um
if i was a dictator oh jesus christ two
things i would do
i'd drive right down to the federal
reserve and arrest everybody in there
okay
and then i would also declassify
everything from the warren commission
and finally end that [ __ ] argument of
what what the [ __ ] happened
um
yeah
that's what i would do all right those
are the first two things off the top of
my head all right
um
i have a bunch of [ __ ] ideas none of
which i could implement
but that's what's great about an idea
it's just an idea it's just a thought
all right that's it go [ __ ] yourselves
i'll check in on you on thursday once
again congratulations to the buffalo
bills um that's one of the big games in
your recent history and you
[ __ ] showed up you came to play
play you did and you won and you
deserved it so congratulations and um if
my team does not make the playoffs i
will be rooting for you
um because there needs to be joy in
buffalo at some point in a sporting way
all right
that is it
the french connection was another high
point in the uh
buffalo bills his buffalo sorry sabres
history that's it all right i'll talk to
you later